- What I am doing and what
I do on a professional basis
everyday, is I take
the meme culture world,
the meme world, prequel
memes, "Star Wars" memes.
I mean some of the best memes out there
are "Star Wars" memes, and you apply that
to politics and you are able to get
an intersectional point
where you can get a young kid
or some young person who
might know "Star Wars,"
but doesn't quite
understand what's going on
with impeachment and you can frame it,
the world for them, based on "Star Wars"
and actually bring them in
to the political process,
which is very important.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and according
to the Wikipedia editors
this is the Rubin Report.
As always guys, make sure
that you're subscribed
to our channel by clicking
subscribe over there
and clicking that notification bell.
And more importantly, joining me today is
the Chief Creative Officer
for Turning Point USA
and meme maker
extraordinaire, Benny Johnson.
- (laughing) Fantastic.
- This feels very overdue, man.
How has this taken so long to happen?
- You're a busy guy.
- You're a busy guy,
going around the world.
Jordan Peterson, it's
like cut his I.Q. in half
you got me.
- (laughing) You're half
of Peterson's brain.
- I'm a very room temperature I.Q.
- Room temperature I.Q.
I'm very comfortable. (laughing)
- Well, I have wanted you on for awhile.
I'm glad we're finally doing this
and before, normally
when I start an interview
I kind of ask people their background,
a little framing of the interview,
but I thought first what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna throw to this video
that you just put up on Instagram.
This is you going to, this outside
of the impeachment hearings?
- Yes.
- Outside of the impeachment hearings,
you're asking questions about politics
and Trump and impeachment
all through the lens
of a little movie called
"Star Wars", here we go.
- Hey everyone, Benny Johnson here
at the United States
Capitol (bell dinging)
where the impeachment trial
of President Trump is ongoing.
The capitol has tens of leftist protestors
gathered at it calling for the impeachment
of President Trump.
Specifically, we're asking
them if "Star Wars" references
about President Trump are worthy
of having him be impeached?
- I am the Senate.
- We're going to see if these
leftist protestors believe
that the President should be impeached,
for instance, of killing
a fictional general,
General Grievous.
- Hello there.
- General Kenobi.
- I can't wait to hear
what they have to say.
Let's go find out.
(upbeat music)
Many people felt a
disturbance in the force
when General Grievous was killed.
What do you think about the
killing of General Grievous
and was it right or wrong?
- Okay, nobody's saying
that he was a good person.
(light sabers buzzing)
But, there are a lot of
bad people in in the world.
And we have laws, everything what we do
with our military should
be according to law.
- I love democracy.
- With new X-wing technology
though there's no,
there's no telling what we can accomplish.
I mean you can get anyone anywhere.
- Yes, yes, absolutely.
- (Obi-Wan Kenobe voiceover)
Use the force, Luke.
("Star Wars" theme music)
- Do you think that it was right
or not right to kill General Grievous?
- Well, it's clearly an assassination.
- Oh, I don't think so.
- People are saying that a
thermal detonator was used
for the assassination, and these
are very dangerous weapons.
Do you have anything to say on that?
You seem to care a lot about this.
- Technically I can't say,
I'm not sure about that yet.
- Because he's holding
a thermal detonator.
- This is just like the kind of music
that was being sang in Mos Eisley Cantina.
It's beautiful.
("Star Wars" Mos Eisley Cantina song)
And General Grievous was
killed by the administration,
by Trump, they were
saying that was illegal.
Do you, do you believe
in those kind of killings
or do you not?
- We have a rule of law.
If that rule of law says,
if I think you're a bad guy
than I should be able to kill you, right?
That's not our rule of law.
- I killed them.
I killed them all.
- Our rule of law is if
I think you're a bad guy
I'm supposed to take you to trial
and prove that you are a bad guy.
That is our rule of law in
the United States of America.
- You can't.
He must stand trial.
- Apparently, he was killed
with thermal detonator.
That's just like, a lot of
concerning to a lot of people.
- Well, and the rule of
law, either we have it
and we need to live by
it, both the citizens
and our government, or we don't
and we don't give a crap
one way or the other.
- My Lord, is that legal?
- I will make it legal.
- Alright, so that's just a small portion
of this video that you put out there
and I think now my
audience understands why
I wanted to throw that before
we do anything else here.
Now that one gentleman at the
end did make a good point.
Should we not have taken
General Grievous in
and put him on trial?
I mean, he was the leader
of the Separatists Army.
He had just taken over from Count Dooku,
who's a horrible human being.
It's a good point.
- Yeah, I mean it's true.
Who knows, I mean, if it was
the Obama administration,
definitely would have
taken him out with a drone,
would have never seen it happening.
It could have even been
an American citizen
would have been, boom,
General Grievous gone.
- When you do these videos,
'cause I know most people
who watch them are going, oh come on,
he must have had to go
to 1000 different people
to get the five.
- First five, first five people.
I kept asking about general Grievous,
and you can see in the
video, I keep pushing them.
Like people felt a
disturbance in the Force,
it's very much a dark side
to have this technology
with a thermal detonator
and X-Wing technology
to kill this general.
No one, nothing.
I even say later in the video that Trump
should just execute an order
66 and dissolve the Senate
and then he can just get rid
of this impeachment fiasco.
- What does this tell
you about these people?
Before we get to the
"Star Wars" element of it
and why "Star Wars" memes really do work.
What does this tell you
about a lot of the activists
that are out there and
people that are purporting
to know everything about politics?
I'm going to talk about these
five people specifically,
but these people that are
just out there protesting
all the time.
And then whenever you see them challenged,
Crowder's really good at this,
they just suddenly know nothing.
- So, the purpose of a video like this is
never actually to make fun of anyone.
What I'm trying to do is show
that there's a bankruptcy
when it comes to the understanding
of why we are impeaching this president.
Why are these people actually
out there protesting?
Every person in the video was protesting
for Trump's impeachment.
Yet, even when asked if
they should impeach Trump
for killing General Grievous,
which was my question.
Should we impeach Trump for killing
a fictional "Star Wars" villain?
They said, yeah.
And so, what I am doing, and what I do
on a professional basis
everyday, is I take
the meme culture world, the meme world,
prequel memes, "Star Wars" memes, I mean
some of the best memes out
there are "Star Wars" memes,
and you apply that to politics.
And you are able to get
an intersectional point
where you can get a young
kid or some young person,
who might know "Star Wars",
but doesn't quite understand
what's going on with impeachment
and you can frame the world
for them based on "Star Wars"
and actually them into
the political process,
which is very important.
- So, what is it about "Star Wars"?
Because I meme the hell out of "Star Wars"
probably only second to you, right?
And there's something
particularly about the prequels
that the memes just, you
know, how does democracy die?
With thunderous applause.
And I am the Senate,
and all of those lines,
they seem so powerful right now.
And what do you think it is
about "Star Wars" specifically
that leads to this?
Where, other movies,
you can meme some things
from other movies, but not
like the endless amount
from "Star Wars" that just feels right
for the moment all the time.
- "Star Wars" was if you
rewind the clock back
to George Lucas, he
based the Empire on Nazis
and he based the Rebellion
on fighting Nazis.
And so, for people like us, particularly,
you are able to find these moral threads
that you pull out of the
basic "Star Wars" story.
The evil of oppressive
overarching brutalist government,
how it tries to squash
hope, how hope must rise
in order to fight that greatest evil,
which is an oppressive
overarching massive,
usually by emergency powers, government
that can take over all of our lives.
And that is the truth
that this was based on.
And I think it hits at a human truth.
Truth that goes all the
way back to our founding
and much of the
renaissance good that comes
from the idea that man is
man and man wants freedom
and man has liberties that
should not be corrupted
and oppressed by a government.
- Well, it's funny because
even though you're doing it
in a funny way there, we
could talk about the idea
that should the Jedi
have captured Grievous,
he was the leader of the
Separatist Army, right,
so he was an insurgent, but
should they have been allowed
to just kill him as Obi-Wan did
or should they have captured
him and taken him for trial?
That actually is an
interesting philosophical point
that we debate all the time
because that's to your point.
That when we killed Soleimani
everyone was saying,
well, you can't just kill the guy.
You have to bring him in for
a trial and the rest of it.
I mean, that really all does
add up to why memes work.
- Yes, correct.
Memes are a piece of non-corporate,
non-establishment media
imagery that reflects a moment in culture.
And reflects something that
we're all going through
and explains it in a very
simple and shareable way.
- I'm pretty sure we could
do the "Star Wars" thing
the entire way, so let's just
do a little bit more though
in case there's anyone
out there watching this
that doesn't have the appreciation
of the "Star Wars" meme
meeting point that we do.
You mentioned something
really interesting to me
right before we started about how the way
the "Star Wars" movies have progressed
or regressed, I suppose, depending
on which way you look at
it, is really reflective
of internet culture in general.
Can you talk about that 'cause I think
it's really super interesting?
- We as consumers of the
product have more value
than we have ever had in the history
of the creation of a thing.
So, you have democratized
the consumer base
for things like "Star
Wars" and "Star Wars"
the fandom menace has
actually saved "Star Wars"
from itself.
- The fandom menace, got it.
- The fandom menace is a real thing
and we can, the feedback
mechanisms are now available
in a decentralized
universe where the studios
have to listen to the consumers.
And where we are able to,
online, demand something
or ask for something or consume at a rate
where it's a feedback loop.
Instead of them just making a "Star Wars"
and hoping we like it,
they make a "Star Wars"
and then we tell them
if we like it, right?
You can hear what happened
after the "Last Jedi"
and the studio heard it and
then desperately J.J. comes in
to try to like fix it.
And there are four to
five different moments
in "The Rise of Skywalker"
where they papered over
what Rey did and that's
because of the response online.
And so, this mechanism can
actually make you more powerful
than the studios producing these things
and the general, I love
democracy, the democracy
of the fandom is actually
a wonderful thing.
Palpatine would be very proud.
- (laughing) Palpatine would be thrilled
at internet trolls, basically.
It's really interesting though.
I mean, that concept is
actually kind of cool
because you know studios
come out with certain things
that often are not good.
And I think the best
version of this in terms
of internet culture is the
all female "Ghostbusters."
It had nothing to do
with it all being women,
but it was a patently terrible movie
and then the audience goes crazy.
And then you get the next layer of this,
which I wanna talk to you about,
which is suddenly the
media that runs protection
for bad movies, right?
And then starts attacking the audiences.
And that's what happened
in "Ghostbusters".
We saw that happen in "Last Jedi" too,
where they say it's all
angry white male trolls
who hate "Last Jedi"
or hate "Ghostbusters"
and it's racist Trump supporters
who hates these things.
And it's the media then
attacking the fan base at,
I don't know, is at the
behest of the studio
or is it just because
the whole machine just
kind of works like that or what?
- I think it has everything to do
with what's going on in society right now.
I cover politics, but the election in 2016
was precisely this bubble.
The same thing that happens
with a "Star Wars" movie
or "Ghostbusters" happened in 2016.
Where you have a group of
people that are so insulated
in their own virtue
signaling and wokedivism
and slackdivism and they must insert that
into everything in their
lives and it blinds them
to understanding what an
actual normal consumer wants.
And so, then you have
the rise of something,
a real anger, that the
things that we cherish
are being destroyed and one
of the last few good things
out there was "Star
Wars" and from both sides
you have this kind of yelp, this anger,
from the base when we
watched "The Last Jedi"
and realize that it is
now just a serving dish
for someone's political world
view and you must eat it.
And it's like, damn it no,
I mean the orcs are not
just at the gate, they've come in
and they've desecrated the temple.
One of the last few things
that we actually all could
come together on was that we
all kind of loved "Star Wars"
and then that destroyed and
you're gonna get backlash.
This happened in 2016,
you got the election
of President Trump and
this is happening now
when it comes to our entire culture,
whether that be "Star
Wars" or "Ghostbusters"
or national politics.
- What do you think about the idea that
because big studios now run
so much of our entertainment
that that also has fed all of this.
Like, the "Star Wars" posters look
exactly like the Marvel posters.
You know what I mean?
It's always the same thing,
the big guy in the middle.
It's Iron Man in the
middle or Rey in the middle
and then everybody else smaller after.
And they look exactly the same,
like the branding is the same.
The messages start becoming the same.
That we don't have new stories anymore.
I said to you right before we started,
I hate to say that in
a way 'cause it's like
I want these stories to continue
and "Mandalorian" was totally fine.
And like I want more out of this,
but it's also like we
need something different.
Like the world has moved
on from George Lucas
having to look at World War II
to then create these characters, you know.
- Yeah, and that is something
that I think people are
very much hungering for
on a national level.
And you're watching
now people running for,
speaking of new stories, I mean, look
at the number of people who
have never been in politics
that are now running and winning
and becoming very very famous.
I don't like AOC, all right,
I don't like AOC in the squad.
I think they're going to wreck the country
if you give them power, but listen,
they have become heroes now
because there's a new story,
there's a new narrative out there.
And of course, the
opposite of that would be
multiple people who have
never had any experience
on the conservative side of
the aisle running for office
and following a Trumpian
model of I am the outsider.
That idea that there's
a new story out there
really gravitates, it
really brings people in.
And again, you have a
president who's pretty much
our version of that elected
outside of the media bubble,
outside of the group think that occurs.
Inside of the corridor between D.C.
and New York and the group think said,
like every Marvel poster looked alike,
every poll looked exactly
the same in 2016, every poll.
Hilary Clinton, remember
the Huffington Post,
98% chance that Hilary will win, right?
Take it to the bank.
You've seen the same compilations I have.
And so, it's like every
poster looks the same
and people start rejecting
it and wanting a new story.
And now you have, arguably,
I mean very easily,
the most powerful man in the world,
the President of the United
States has been elected
because people were so desperate
and hungry for a new story
and rejecting the same
stuff that's been forced
on us for decades.
- Alright, before we go too
far into the Trump thing
and I wanna talk impeachment
and how this is all related
to media and all that.
Now let's go to where I
usually start the interviews,
which is how the hell did you
get into this whole thing?
Like what brought Benny
Johnson to sit here right now
and talk to me about "Star Wars"?
- I was raised in Iowa
and Iowa's a magical place
where you can really
see candidates up close.
One of things that we
force every candidate
who wants to be president to
do is eat pork chop on a stick.
You wanna dehumanize someone,
I mean you really wanna
break them down to their
core elements, right?
Force someone like Hilary Clinton to eat
a pork chop on a stick
in a 120 degree humid day
in the middle of Iowa State Fair.
- Remember that picture
of Michelle Bachmann
eatin' the corn dog and
you had Romney trying it.
Like Romney was one of the worst ones.
- No one looks good eating a corn dog.
No one looks good eating a
sweaty pork chop on a stick.
- Did you grow up going to those fairs
and going to the straw
polls and the rest of it?
- Yes, yes.
So, you got to see the real human being
behind the politician.
You got to see little quirks,
little things of them.
As a young guy in politics I
was just in student government
at my college and at my high school.
You would get taken out to a
Subway by a Mitt Romney, right?
He would take you out to Subway.
You get to watch the man
eat his Subway sandwich.
You get to see the human
side of the politician
and it was something
that was always lacking
because they always came
off as such a stiff veneer
when you see them on stage.
And so, I began to really gravitate
towards telling stories
differently for the political class
and inside the political bubble
and that began a career in making
viral content about politics.
I've done this now for over a decade
and I've always wanted to
bring and mesh the worlds
that a lot of young people understand,
which is the cultural world,
and mesh that in with politics
so that people understand the
political world around them
because, quite frankly, that's
the most important thing
you can understand as an American.
- So, as an Iowa guy, is
it shocking or strange
or backwards or is it the
way it's suppose to be
that in just a few weeks
that this straw poll,
which seems so antiquated and ridiculous
in so many ways, is
the thing that is going
to set the next eight
months in motion, really?
We're just in the lead
up, we're in preseason
right now still, even
though it all feels crazy,
but the straw poll starts this whole thing
and someone could get
momentum out of nowhere.
And if Biden does really bad
he's no longer the front runner.
Does that seem crazy to you as
someone that grew up in Iowa?
- It's like the various gladiator
feats of strength, okay,
to get there, federalism.
I mean, it's one of the last
cherished things of federalism
is that every State is different.
And the way that this
was suppose to work is
every State was suppose to be
their own actual governance
and the States wouldn't
of even come together
and signed the Constitution
if we didn't write,
as a libertarian you know
this, very firm grounds
of federalism that each State was unique.
- Which we're washing away very quickly.
- Very quickly, horrifyingly,
horrifyingly so.
Iowa you're gonna have to
go eat pork chop on a stick
and appeal to Iowans
to get the Iowan vote.
New Hampshire you're gonna have to go
and, what do they do in New
Hampshire, tap a maple tree.
Get like the special ski
slope maple tree like vote.
New Hampshire, I'm not from there,
I don't know much about anything.
- I'm not condemning Iowa in any way
as much as like the process.
Like it's always the
same order every year.
Like it almost seems like
we have to mix up the order
because than it all just
becomes so entrenched
that the fakery is too obvious
or something like that.
- I don't much about why
the process is what it is.
I know that every State votes.
- I don't think anyone
knows at this point.
- But, it is special that you have to go
and you have to earn the
vote of a specific group
of people living in a specific
State and appeal to them
and I love that process.
I think it's great.
- You wanna make a crazy
prediction out of Iowa?
- Bernie.
- I was gonna ask you some
predictions at the end.
So really?
- Yeah, Bernie.
- So, are you feeling
this thing right now?
'Cause there does seem
to be a certain momentum
for Bernie right now.
That the mainstream media has
really tried to take him out.
Now, again, I know you and
I are not fans of his ideas
let's say, but the
mainstream has just been
going after the guy
relentlessly and Warren tried
some stuff and women
aren't gonna be elected
and the rest of it.
But, do you feel like
he's just got this thing
whether the DNC wants it to happen or not?
- Yeah, and Joe Rogan,
one of your colleagues,
one of the people who are so special
in this decentralized media industry
kind of said it the best, which is
the guys just been a
communist his whole life
and he's just told everyone
about his communism forever
and that sort of authenticity
is really valuable now.
Authenticity is the
currency of the internet.
People know if you're being fake
and people know if
you're putting on a show.
And when someone like Bernie who's just
an old crusty communist, who has just been
an old crusty communist his entire life.
Honeymoon in the Soviet
Union, let's not forget,
when he comes in to an age
that's internet centric
then his authenticity
really shines through
and people really gravitate to that.
It's the same thing that brought
a lot of people over to Trump.
And it's this thing that
is really, I think, driving
the boom right now for Bernie
that is putting him now
up ahead double digits in New Hampshire,
up ahead almost double digits in Iowa.
I think that like I am the same guy
that I've always been is something
that is more attractive
now than ever before.
- That's the funny thing
about the Rogan endorsement.
It's like just saying that
someone hasn't changed
isn't in and of itself
so great, but I get you.
There's a consistency there, I suppose,
that people like, but you may have
all the wrong ideas within that.
- Yes, but authenticity, I mean,
people will gravitate
to something authentic
more than ever today and it's
because we've been trained
to do this based on what
we like on social media.
The authenticity that we
see into people's lives
and we know have access
into everyone's life.
People can figure out
what Dave Rubin likes.
People can follow you on social media
and see the things.
- See what I hate.
- Yeah, and see what you
love and what you hate
and they can tell if
you're an authentic person.
And we are now demanding that
inside of our politicians
and like it or not that's
part of the reason why
people just adore the
President of the United States
right now, is because there's
nothing but lying with him.
You're gonna hear his unvarnished opinions
regardless of whether you love them or not
you're going to see
directly inside of his brain
and what's going on and
you're gonna that find out
through his social media
and through Twitter.
And that's what endears
so many Americans to that.
We've been trained to want that.
- Alright, so how the
hell does Trump understand
all this stuff?
I've asked a million guests this.
Everyone has their own theory.
But, how does Trump get the meme wars,
the edge lords, the trolls, the Russians,
the whole damn thing,
how does Trump get it?
I think you have a little insight maybe
into what he's thinking or
you've been around him enough
in the Turning Point world.
- Trump has always been
a creature of the media.
He's always very much understood media.
And every era that he's lived in
from the '70s, '80s, '90s to today
he's understood media and how
people consume information.
Where is the audience?
And he's always understood audience.
Now, you have to ask yourself,
if you're talking about
the modern media landscape,
what is a media company?
A media company is where the audience is.
And Trump has very elegantly navigated
to the place where the audience is
every single iteration of his career.
And it's been very very special to watch
how the guy, at 70 years
old, has just mastered
the meme wars and just mastered
the art of social media.
And a new generation of
kids, that's where they are.
That's where they're
getting their information.
- Do you think the world was just waiting
for someone like him?
Like, it didn't actually have to be him,
but that because of everything
you're talking about
and the way that things have changed
and watch mainstream media crumble
and the internet rise and all that,
that is was gonna be
somebody to do this reckoning
and he just happened to be the guy?
Or do you think that
really is unique about him?
The lens that he views the world
because of the way he survived media
over decades and all that?
- Yeah, I think we're
living in the golden age
of memes and politics and
Trump has brought that about.
And the world was waiting
for someone to create
the diad in the force
that was the president.
- I'm gonna see how many
more "Star Wars" references
you can force in here, we'll see.
- (laughing) Force in here,
love what you just did there, Dave.
The world was waiting for the
internet president, right?
The president who fully
understood the internet
and brought it with
him to the White House.
And Barack Obama bringing
in YouTube celebrities,
that's one thing, but Barack Obama was not
the internet president, not at all.
The internet president is Donald Trump
who hosts the social media
summit at the White House.
I had the honor of being invited to it
and you walk in to the
foyer of the White House,
I mean, famous, it's
been all Hollywood movies
from the time of Lincoln,
and there are huge memes
printed out on boards
hanging in the grand foyer
of the White House, Dave.
Like this is the world
I've been begging for
my entire career.
You walk around, you look, there's a meme
and there's a "Game of Thrones" meme.
And they're all there like hanging inside
of the most sacred
house in America, right?
The most cherished and
valuable piece of real estate
in the country is the White House.
One of the most recognizable places
on planet earth is the White
House and here are memes
hanging inside of the grand
foyer of the White House.
This is actually the internet president.
I think it's really fundamental
that Trump gets audience.
He understands where an audience is.
And right now, today, there
has been a dynamic shift
in where people actually are.
And where people are are platforms
and where they wanna get their
information are platforms
and from influencers.
And Trump, is a base influencer out there.
- So, the last time we
actually saw each other
in person was at the Turning
Point Student Action Summit
about a week before Christmas,
a couple days before Christmas,
I spoke that morning.
You were sort of the MC
of the whole thing, right?
You're shooting T-shirts into the crowd
and you were getting everybody going,
but you didn't warm up the
crowd for me that morning.
I don't know what you were
doing that Saturday morning.
I wasn't gonna bring this up,
I don't know what happened.
I did okay, that's not even the point.
I did just fine, the point is,
that I spoke in the morning
and then Trump spoke later
in the afternoon and then when he spoke
it was the first time that
I ever heard him speak live.
And it did help crystallize
one thing for me,
which is how the media takes
an hour and a half speech
that he gives and how
they really extrapolate
whatever they want out of it.
'Cause there's a moment
that I'm sure you remember
where Trump gets up there and he goes,
I know more about windmills than anybody.
I've been studying
windmills my whole life.
And then he goes on this
riff about windmills.
Now, obviously, he doesn't know more
about windmills than everybody,
obviously he's not studying windmills,
but he makes some interesting points
about how they build windmills
and all of this other stuff,
but then I saw it happen.
So he does this speech and he's sort of
basically like a comic
and he's working the room
and he kind of goes off
script and then comes back.
But then it was the next part,
and this is where I really,
it all kind of crystallized for me,
was then later that afternoon
what do I see, of course?
Vox, Media Matter, the rest of it
with all of their headlines,
Donald Trump claims
he knows more about
windmills than anybody.
Donald Trump claims he's studied
windmills his whole life.
And it's like, did he say that?
He did.
Is that in context?
No.
Do you understand sarcasm?
And it's like when you
really see it that way
it did shift the whole thing for me.
To actually be there and
then see the headlines.
- Yes.
There is such a thing as sarcasm,
humor still in the world.
It's not literate, it's not literal.
- Also not literate.
- Both actually.
But, a good meme is something that takes,
that is funny, it uses
humor, it uses pop culture
to connote a greater truth
about the world around us.
And Donald Trump speaks in memes.
That's what a lot of people
I don't think understand,
is that this era was
actually made for him.
When Donald Trump looks Hilary
Clinton in the eye and goes,
'cause you'd be in jail.
That's like an impact font meme.
That was a meme, right?
Like that was one of the most memorable,
maybe perhaps the most memorable
if you play it on a big
screen to an audience,
which I do regularly, the
most memorable moment in 2016.
And that was Trump just
speaking in a meme.
Short sentences, understandable
dialogue, joke, sarcasm,
but hitting a deeper truth.
And that's the way the president speaks,
and the hyper-literal,
perpetually wanting to be offended
corporate media that exists
today they don't get him,
but at that peril.
Because Trump is speaking
the way the internet speaks
and the way that consumers
speak and the way
that the audiences of the future speak.
And the audiences of the future want
to get their information from memes.
I give this speech around the country.
Tens of thousands of
students around the country
I speak to every single year
and it's a huge privilege
of mine to do that, but I
ask them with regularity
where would you prefer
to get your information?
Raise your hand if you want
to get your information
from a meme.
If you'd prefer it in that form?
And thousands of hands
go, I'm telling you Dave,
thousands of hands go
up from the students.
I take a cell phone out of my pocket,
I do this thought test all the time.
put it on the table and I
say this cell phone is yours.
It's free, you can get it
free of charge, one rule,
coded in to the actual iPhone, brand new,
is that you can only download one app
to get your news and information from.
What app do you download?
I ask kids this, it doesn't
matter if it's 50 kids
in a small room or 500 kids or 5000 kids,
it's always the same.
- I'm guessing the
answer is Twitter, right?
But, tell me it's TikTok
and I'm gonna jump,
we don't have windows in here.
- It's a mix.
A lot of Instagrams, I would say probably
eight out of 10 is an Instagram.
- That's interesting.
- Now again, these are school aged kids.
Eight out of 10 is an Instagram.
You always have your
outliers who'll say Reddit.
Very rarely, but Facebook.
You get YouTube, a lot of
YouTubes and some Twitters.
It kind of depends on
the diet of the student.
Here's something that never,
ever is said, MSNBC, CNN.
- Well, CNN, when I give
a speech to college kids
sometimes I say something
about CNN, not to be funny.
I'm like, well, you
know CNN is one channel
and they laugh when I say CNN
as if that's the punchline
'cause it's so absurd to them.
- I don't think it's even partisan, Dave.
I think, they don't say Fox News either.
They want to get their information from,
and I'm just gonna be complimentary here,
you, from a decentralized
non-corporate influencer
who is going to bring them the information
that they trust you.
They trust guys like me,
they trust influencers.
They want, we are the
new nightly news anchors.
Memes are our new news program, right?
And the new broadcast
networks are these platforms
that they can follow us on and see more
of a dimensionality of us
and the world around them.
And that's how they prefer
to get their information.
- Isn't it amazing, so
obviously I agree with you
in the broad sense there.
It's like all the mainstream
media then had to do
was sort of incorporate some of us
instead of trying to destroy all of us,
which is what they chose
to do instead, right?
They decided to say we're all bigots
and racists and all the rest of it.
And try to crush our
jobs and crush our reach
on top of big tech and everything else,
but all they had to was
bring on a couple guys.
ABC all they probably
had to do, or forget ABC,
CNN six years ago your phone coulda rang
and they coulda been
like can you be the guy
that takes us into the new thing, Benny?
And then they maybe they
wouldn't be in this situation.
And yet, that tells you
about the archaic nature
of the machine.
- There's an industry story
about Blockbuster's valuation
and Netflix's valuation and
you've seen the same chart
that I've seen.
Blockbuster could have buried Netflix
for a decade of Netflix's existence,
but instead they chose to laugh at them
and they said we're Blockbuster
this will never happen.
- You're gonna mail those
things to these people?
- Right, no one every
wants a DVD in the mail,
this is not a problem.
And now, we are looking at
2020 and Netflix is winning
Golden Globes and they win
Oscar this year, right?
- And isn't there one Blockbuster?
- There's one left in Alaska.
- It's in Alaska?
- Yes.
- Is that right?
And there's this inflection point
where your industry gets overtaken
and people no longer need gas lanterns,
they have light bulbs.
- Are you worried about that though?
Does any level of that worry you?
- So, something that's been interesting
about the de-masking of corporate media,
specifically on places like CNN,
is that you're able to
see in the era of Trump
who they always were.
You're able to see like a
viral clip that's going around
right now is this clip of Don Lemon.
- We're gonna play the clip.
So why don't we play this clip first.
This clip is from about a week ago.
I mentioned this when I had
Michael Malice on last week.
We did a little dissection, but I think
it would be great to get
your dissection of this too.
So, this is Don Lemon's CNN program.
- And obviously it's false.
And look, he also knows deep in his heart
that Donald Trump couldn't
find Ukraine on a map
if you had the letter U and a picture
of an actual physical crane next to it.
He knows that this is, you
know, and administration defined
by ignorance of the world.
And so, that's partly him
playing to their base.
(Don Lemon laughing loudly)
And playing to their audience, you know,
the credulous Boomer rube
demo that backs Donald Trump
that wants to think Donald
Trump's the smart one
and you all elitists are dumb.
(all laughing)
- You elitists with your
geography and your maps
and your spelling.
- And your math and your reading.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, your reading, ya know.
Your geography, knowing other
countries, sipping a latte.
- All those lines on the map.
(all laughing loudly)
- Only them elitists
know where Ukraine is.
Sorry, I apologize.
- Oh my gosh.
- But you know what?
It was Rick's fault, I blame Rick.
But in all honesty.
- Blame NPR, why not?
- Sorry, hold on, wait, wait,
you guys give me a second.
Hold on, hold on, hold on. (laughing)
That was good, sorry.
Rick, that was a good one, I needed that.
- It's so deeply fake,
the laughter is fake.
Nobody's laughing that hard at that joke.
The banter is fake, the
whole damn thing, fake news.
Someone said fake news somewhere
at one point, fake news.
- So, why should you be,
that rightfully makes
a lot of people angry, that clip,
but why you should be
encouraged by that clip actually
is that it happened a week
before it really went viral.
So few people were
watching Don Lemon's show
that no one even noticed.
They were just screaming into the abyss.
They were screaming into
the woods that the tree fell
and no one heard it.
And I know for a fact, I know for a fact
'cause I can pull the Nielsen
ratings, that good videos
that we make at Turning
Point get more viewers
than CNN's entire nightly lineup.
This show, Dave Rubin's show,
gets more viewers per video
than many headline news shows on CNN.
A good video with you
and Shapiro and Peterson
will get more viewers than
CNN's ratings the whole week.
- For a month probably.
- Yes, correct.
- In some cases.
- So, what is this inflection point?
It's really special,
it shows the one thing
that is so important in media is audience.
Where is your audience?
Who has it?
And where is the audience going?
And the fact that that can happen
and no one even knows that it's happening
because so few people are
watching this news show.
Let's remember, it'll make
you sick to your stomach,
that's a news show, that's listed as a,
that's in the CNN news
lineup, Don Lemon's show.
I know you don't say it Don
Lemon, but it makes him angry,
so it's funny to say.
That's how depressing it
is, and if you're looking,
young people are not watching that.
The clip would have gone viral instantly
if people had actually
been watching the show.
- But, what do you make of
the cognitive dissonance
of these people, the same
people who said the deplorables,
thus thrusting Trump to
victory, are now doing that.
Making fun of people's accents, making fun
of people's education,
all of those things.
When it's like, let's pretend for a moment
that they're less educated
and that's why they're voting for Trump.
Aren't you suppose to be a good lefty
who would want to help
educate these people?
I mean, the smugness of it is, I think,
I get the media side of
it, but it's the detachment
from what they purport
to believe, politically
or philosophically that
I find more disturbing.
- So that's going back
to authenticity being
the currency of the internet.
People want to know where their
information is coming from.
I am a conservative,
you are a libertarian,
people understand that who
are tuning into this show
and that's okay.
The de-masking is showing clips like that
where they are now unvarnished
presenting themselves
as the leftist propagandists
that they actually are
and that veneer of objectivity
has been utterly destroyed.
The carpet has been rent,
the curtain has been ripped,
there's no such thing
as objectivity anymore
and that's okay as long as you're prepared
for the new thing coming, which is this.
Which is understanding that
Dave Rubin is a libertarian
and he's gonna come at it from
libertarian point of view.
That's okay.
- Yeah, and you're also gonna
watch us work through it
in real time, which is one of the things.
It's why I do the events that
I always do at Turning Point
where I go up there and I
always make a point of saying,
guys, I'm gonna say a few things
that I know most of you disagree with.
And not only do I get invited back,
but if anything I think that's why
I'm getting invited in the first place.
- Yes, and you're one of
the most popular speakers.
And maybe 40% of your
speech is not necessarily
the exact thing that
the audience believes.
That's okay, they love you.
- Half of my speech last
time was about "Star Wars"
'cause it had just come out.
The funny thing is, I didn't
want to lead to much remember?
So, I wasn't talking too
much about "Star Wars"
and then we do Q and A and
I always say to the kids,
students, whatever, I always say
if you disagree with me come up first
and yet, all the questions
were about "Star Wars."
And I was like, wait a minute guys,
let me get this straight,
I give a political speech,
the President of the United
States is speaking here
in an hour and you're
asking me about "Star Wars."
And everyone was like going crazy.
- It's why you gotta ask
questions about General Grievous.
That's why you have to use "Star Wars",
us the billions that have been put in
to tell even the "Star Wars" story
to tell a story about politics,
about the things that are
going on in the world today.
And the people that really understand that
are the people that understand
where audience is going.
And this is where audience is going.
They can laugh and they can be Nero
and strum the harp while Rome burns,
which is what I get when
I watch a clip like that.
When I watch a clip like that
I think about Rome burning
and about Nero playing his harp.
And that's just them
laughing and cackling,
being the last little elitists
on their little pedal stools
as their ratings are crumbling,
as their advertising dollars
are going through the floor
and as people are tuning
out in record numbers
and as they're being
be-clowned, quite literally,
on a daily basis, that is Rome burning.
- Do you ever think when one
of these clips is going viral
and again, I think you made
a really interesting point,
that this existed before it went viral,
which shows you that no one
is really watching this stuff.
But, do you ever think, ah,
maybe we should just let it be
and I shouldn't jump
in on it on every clip
'cause sometimes I feel that.
'Cause, you know you see these
things happening on Twitter
and you see everyone
kind of doing their thing
and making it bigger.
And then's there's this
other part of me that's like,
you know what, if we all just
started ignoring all of this
that we could really
be maybe better focused
on whatever it is that we
individually are trying to build,
rather than taking that thing down.
Do you think about that ever?
- Well, you brought it
up, that you're attacked.
They call you a racist or a Nazi for being
on something other than a
corporate media platform, right?
Instead of inviting us in and
having to do the hard thing,
which is diversity of
opinion and actually lean in
to diversity of opinion, they
do the thing that losers do.
I'm not saying that in
the sense like losers,
I'm saying that in the
sense of these are tactics
of people that are losing.
They're losing their base
and they're losing their cultural war
and when you see them cackling
about Trump supporters
and mocking accents and Southern accents
and things like that, mocking
people's careers and jobs,
that's the tactic of a loser.
That's not the tactic of a winner.
That's the tactic of a losing side
that's attempting to score cheap points
on someone who has already defeated them.
- Right, like who are you bringing over
when you're doing that?
Does anyone watch that and go, oh,
these guys they really get it?
Like I guess, yeah, there's
the sliver of the base
that's in on the joke
or something like that,
but do you get anyone,
anyone that they would want
to bring over to them?
- I am thrilled when liberals
slide right in to my DM
and talk about how much
they hate me and my content.
And this happens, of
course, you know this,
this happens on a minute by minute basis,
but if my content is reaching them.
The "Star Wars" video pisses
off a ton of people, right?
You tricked them into
thinking General Grievous,
he was killed in Iran.
- You also piss off the of
ruining Grievous' good name.
- Of course, like everyone knows
that a thermal detonator wasn't used
to kill General Grievous, right?
Like, what are you thinking?
If I can just bring you
in the conversation.
into the conversation
and we can start that dialogue,
that's huge success for me.
- So, as a conservative, and a
relatively young conservative
are you kind of shocked.
- Relatively?
- Relatively, I don't know,
you wanna say how old you are?
- I'm 33.
- I'll leave that up to you.
33, but for a conservative,
you know what I mean?
You know, if you listen
to MSNBC conservatives
are suppose to be stodgy old white men.
So, as a relatively young
conservative though,
are you shocked how sort of wide
the conservative tent
is becoming right now?
- Yeah.
Well, I mean look at conservative
heroes, viral heroes.
Let's start off, you have
Ben Shapiro, he comes
from a very specific and very
unique minority world view
with Orthodox Judaism.
You have Candace Owens
coming from a very specific,
very, like world view that is
almost a dynamic unto itself.
You're not able to mix
people like Andy Ngo
who's doing the best reporting on Antifa.
Scott Presler, the young
roster of conservative heroes
is so diverse it really is,
gives you hope for the future.
I work with Charlie Kirk every single day.
I know he's been on this show.
And it's amazing to
think, my god, he's 26.
- So something interesting
happened a couple months ago.
There started to be this like rise
of what I would say are genuinely
sort of far-right people
that were going after Charlie,
going after Turning Point,
showed up to my events, probably showed up
to things that you were doing.
And one of the things that
I was super impressed by
was the level of fight that
I saw people on the right
fighting these people.
What I see on the left,
and my audience knows
how I feel about this already obviously,
that the left there's
nothing too far left.
Ilhan Omar's not left enough
and Sarsour's not too far left.
You're never too left or bananas
to be associated with on that side.
But, the right does set limits.
And I think that was
pretty damn impressive,
I say by you guys, because
it was a real attack
on Turning Point.
And you guys fought back
and I would say won,
in whatever the hell.
- Shapiro was there to help.
I mean, Ben gave, I think,
a very Churchillian speech
to really like break it all down.
Charlie did this multiple places.
- This was a sudden group
of like, I would say,
like real race focused
Nationalists, something like that.
- I think that's what separates
us from the left though,
is having the courage to say,
you're not part of our party.
We disown you and these
views we do not want
inside of our tent.
- By the way, did you see
that, I'm sure you saw it,
that Stelter clip on CNN where they show
these like race realists
protesting Donald Trump Jr.,
with Charlie on stage with him,
they're attacking Trump
Jr., Trump Jr. is fighting
against the racists, the
guys that are screaming
about all this stuff, and then CNN says,
Trump Jr. is fighting
against the conservatives.
It was something like
the real conservatives
or something like that, to
imply that real conservatives
are racists and somehow Trump
Jr. was sort of the good guy
or like, it's all so confusing.
- It's too confusing, but it's
very basic in its element,
which is that if you are a racist
or if you are an anti-Semite
you have no quarter
in my movement.
Those are things that I
don't play footsie with.
And we will disown you and
if those are the things,
if that's your world view
that's not going to be part
of the movement that we are creating.
It's as simple as that.
CNN can try and conflate
that and people can try
and conflate that all they want,
but it's just really clear
when you lay out the words
that are being said
and what is being said.
It's really stark, but it takes bravery
to do a thing like that and it also takes
a little bit of moral courage
and it'd be really exciting
to watch that type of a
disownment of anti-Semitism
and of the views that play footsie with
or just openly embrace terrorist regimes
and anti-Semitic tropes
that happen on the left,
to have it on both sides.
Isn't this one of the few
things we should agree on, Dave?
- Well, that's why the thing
that happened with Rogan
was so crazy.
It's like you got lefties
screaming that Bernie
has to disown Joe Rogan,
but he doesn't have
to disown Linda Sarsour.
He doesn't have to disown Ilhan Omar.
- Or Rashida Tlaib who's out
on the campaign trail with him.
Out on the campaign trail
with him on a regular basis,
someone who says the Holocaust
gives her a calming feeling.
This is just shocking
that Rogan is the guy
who needs to be deep-sixed.
- Yeah, we gotta take
Rogan out outta this crew.
- But, we're all going
to embrace Michael Moore,
literally communist Michael
Moore, communist AOC,
and open anti-Semite Rashida
Tlaib and Ilhan Omar.
- Let's shift a little bit
to this impeachment thing.
Have you heard about this?
Have you heard that
something's going down?
- Ya know what's funny
is that I live in D.C..
I've lived in D.C. for ten years.
I made my bones in Washington
and I like being close
to my subject matter, right?
It's very important to
understand how these people
tick behind the scenes,
so I have a very pulse
on D.C. and Washington and how it works.
I pride myself on this,
I set myself to it.
You wouldn't know impeachment's
going on in Washington.
You can sense when
something big is happening.
Kavanaugh for instance,
this is an example.
The entire city being
enraptured by a thing
that's happening that affects us all.
You can't go to a coffee shop
and you can't take the Metro
without seeing Kavanaugh's
face, without hearing about,
without having someone come
up and talk to you about it.
People yelling in the streets.
People screaming on both
sides, ripping signs.
That's a thing that takes
over the entire city.
Impeachment is like the
government took a Xanax.
Like everyone's out cold.
- It feels like "The Producers" sort of.
Like it's a show that nobody's going to.
That's not exactly what
"The Producers" was,
but it's like a show
that they wanted to fail
that then became a success.
- Is this gonna be a
"Springtime for Miller" joke?
You try to work the
"Springtime for Miller" in.
- But, that's not quite
the right analogy there.
But, I can tell you why you're right
because when I was on tour with Peterson
it was the middle of the Kavanaugh thing
and we were doing a Q and A in Ireland
and people were asking us
about the Kavanaugh thing.
And I thought how bananas is this.
I'm in Dublin and people can
ask Jordan anything they want
and they're asking him his thoughts
on the Supreme Court Justice,
the potential Supreme Court
Justice of the United States.
Like, that has no bearing
on their lives whatsoever.
There's a million other things that
this guy could talk about that
would directly affect them.
But, it's like I don't
think anyone over there is
talking about it because nobody's talking.
My neighbor, I kid you
not, I was walking the dog
the other day, the neighbor came up to me
and he knows what I am and what I do.
And he was like, so, how
about that impeachment thing?
And the way he laughed was like,
I don't even know what his
political feelings are,
but he laughed as if like it's just like
you would say it to somebody.
It doesn't mean anything,
but it's like saying
what's the weather like,
you know what I mean?
It was just like that's it.
- It's catastrophic.
If you look at the polling.
If you look at democrat
voters, they don't care.
And if you wanna put a
bow on this whole thing,
what is the establishment
corporate media been covering
non-stop 24/7 wall-to-wall since October?
Impeachment.
They have been making the
case and doing there best,
many of them propagandists for the DNC,
making their best case for
impeachment of President Trump.
And a guy like me who
has a show where I go out
into the streets and talk with people.
I went out into the streets
in Florida, a swing State,
a very political State, and asked people
if they had been convinced
or if they even knew why
the president was being impeached.
And the responses that I got
in two straight hours of asking
probably four or five dozen people was no.
I mean, quite frankly, no.
They don't, they haven't been convinced.
They don't really understand
why it's happening
and all of the full force and weight
of full establishment media
and everything they've built
and their entire kingdoms come together
to cover one thing and no one cares.
And it's not getting through
and it's not making sense.
But, you know what does fly,
like a meme on my Instagram
about how stupid impeachment
is and General Grievous.
- Yeah.
- Are you worried,
putting aside the reasons
that you enjoy the meme
wars and everything else?
I mean, are you worried
that even if Trump wins
that the stage has been set here
that they'll just try another
impeachment after this
and they'll just try another.
That, sort of that the ship has sailed,
they've said this is
the route we're going.
Their saying now, the new
thing is he's not gonna,
he won't leave the presidency
and that's another reason
we have to impeach him, he won't leave.
I mean they're the ones that
won't accept the last election.
Like, there's so many backwards,
they usually tell you
more about themselves
when they're claiming what
Trump will or won't do.
But, are you worried about that just
for the health of the Republic?
I'm worried about that, actually.
That, let's say, Trump wins
again, which I suspect he will,
that if that happens that we then just get
another four years of this.
And we'll ultimately of had six years
of just endless nonsense.
And then how do you ever get out of that.
- How do you get out of it?
- As I said, I had Michael
Malice on last week,
he loves it.
He says we should be in that all the time
'cause he likes the energy of that.
But you, as an energy guy,
like through the internet,
does that worry you?
- There's no energy
there, that's what's crazy
about being in Washington,
being on the ground,
is that there really is no energy there.
Something happened this last week.
Two big things, impeachment
and March for Life.
March for Life had hundreds
of thousands of people at it.
They cities a nightmare,
the cities catastrophic
at the March for Life,
whether Trump speaks or not.
Trump spoke, catastrophic,
cant' get anywhere.
I mean, it's easier to find
a life boat on the Titanic
than to try to find an open Uber
or to try and get anywhere
in the messed up grid
because there's so many
people in the city.
There were multiple impeachment
protests, I covered them.
It was legitimately tens
of people showing up.
I can tell you honestly, I'm
trying to make fun of 'em,
I can tell you honestly less
than 100 people showed up
to each of these pro-impeachment rallies.
It is not something
that, it's not something
that there really is any
energy at on that level,
on the grassroots level
and polling shows this.
Polling shows that
democrat voters are like
just get it over with,
just get it over with.
Let's move on, this isn't helpful.
- Do you think the Democrat
party survives this thing?
I actually think this might
be the end of Democratic party
as we know it.
And it's gonna split into
something else after this.
- Well, I mean, with your past you would
perhaps know better than me.
- (laughing) I have usually
been right on what's going on
with these people.
I suspect that they
cannot survive this thing.
This will unearth all of the stuff.
It will cause the more radical
socialists to go there way
and the blue dogs are all gone anyway,
but if you're a decent liberal
this has nothing to do with you anymore.
- So, decent liberal, such a great point
that you just brought up.
Decent liberal, Pete
Buttigieg, viral clip this week
about him dunking on
the pro-life democrat.
A lot of democrats are Catholic, right?
You're pro-life if you're Catholic.
- So, this was at a town
hall and she basically said,
is there room for me in the
party as a pro-life Democrat.
- And he said get out.
And he's nice about it.
Pete Buttigieg, nice guy, he said get out
of our party, leave.
This is not the tactics
of a winning movement.
So, take a step back and look
at tactics of people who win.
They can allow diversity.
They can allow diversity of thought.
They can be open to the world as it is
and they wish to attract more.
They wish to bring in
more, like let's create
and let's get unique and let's
come up with new stories.
The tactic of a loser is
people who have to sensor
or control speech.
People who are horrified of new ideas.
People that are dogmatic in
their belief system politically
and who try to expel the
people who offend them.
And what parties do those
two world views represent?
And then that's very easy when
you crystallize it that way
which side is the losing side.
The losing side right now is wokedivism,
activist-left, who have
taken over the host,
which is the democratic party
to try to push the world view
and it is really isolating and you have
a presidential candidate
who, odds on right now,
the betting world says Bernie Sanders.
Whew, try and run an actual
communist in America.
- Do you think Trump wants that though?
It almost seems like
that's where we have to get
to this thing, like to
really kill this thing.
And I did this post on New Years Day
that went pretty viral about
how this will be the end year
of the woke stuff.
It never gets fully killed, but I think
this will be the year
that it fundamentally gets
crushed enough to change
or cause the split
in the DNC, but it seems to me that
if you get the Trump Sanders thing
then everyone can just
put all their cards out
on the table at that point, right.
It's basically capitalism
versus socialism,
what do you want people?
And the entire world, by the way,
will be voting for Trump because nobody,
no sane person in any
other country wants America
to become socialist.
- No, no.
- Yeah, that's hard to explain to people
free in America for some reason.
- This is why there's open
warfare right now on Bernie,
open warfare.
Democrat establishment are full of people
who are investors, who are very wealthy,
who have made money off
the capitalist system
and they do not want to lose it all.
They do not want to give it all away.
- I have I told you my
crazy Bloomberg theory?
- No, let's hear it.
- My crazy Bloomberg theory
is that Bloomberg is running
as an insurance policy to
ensure that Trump wins.
I know that sounds
nuts, but the idea being
that if Bernie gets it Bloomberg runs
so that he can get maybe five percent
of the decent democrats,
the old-school liberals,
thus making sure that Bernie loses.
Because for as much as
Bloomberg hates Trump
he at least likes capitalism.
- Yes.
- I know that sounds nuts.
- And he likes to trade with China.
And he likes that trade lane being open.
And yeah, Bernie does not.
I'll tell ya, if Bloomberg
does not get the nomination
and if he does not become
president he can still,
there's still a position open for him
that he will be beloved and cherished
throughout the land for and
that I think he's perfect for,
which is playing baby
Yoda in the next season
of the "Mandalorian."
He's the perfect size, he'd
fit in the costume, alright,
and he has like the sensibility.
I think he has the
sensibility to play baby Yoda
season two, "Mandalorian."
If you're out there,
okay, if you're listening.
- Yeah.
- That might be a possibility.
- He'd be great, perfect size.
- He's a small guy.
Yeah, I know nobody likes
being in the prediction game,
but you think Trumps just
gonna run away with this thing
like gangbusters kinda.
- I'm an optimist, right,
but I'm also a realist.
And you live in D.C. long enough,
you get real beaten down
as a conservative in D.C.
for the last couple
cycles and then you look
at the actual data that is
being produced right now
from swing States, from
the general electorate,
and the same things that
have always been true
are true still today in the sense that
people won't vote against
a thing that helps them.
The American economy is
doing better than it's done
perhaps in the history of this country.
There is a lot of data to support that.
And that certain groups that
typically have a rough go
are doing better than they have ever done
in the history of this country
and that people will not vote
against their own interests.
And right now, economically, things are
just going gangbusters and
so it just doesn't matter
if Trump kills General Grievous
with a thermal detonator.
People are going to not vote
against their own self-interest.
- Is there anything in
the conservative movement
that you're not happy with at the moment?
Are the conservatives missing anything?
Are they coming up short?
- Yeah.
- Where would that be?
Or what would that be?
- There's still a entrenched establishment
in the city that likes
communicating in the old way.
They still like doing things the old way
and very much like media's going through
their own inception point
and changing drastically,
there is an establishment
conservative in D.C.
that, if you read the
headlines, Trump is always
at odds with, that like
doing things their own way.
That way was controlled
decline and I hate that
with the very soul of my being.
- So, when you say controlled decline
that was basically Jeb, McCain, Romney,
like you kinda play by their
rules, but you lose everything.
- We've lost, the world
view comes from this,
we've lost the culture war.
We've lost the political landscape war.
We've lost the colleges, we've
lost the education system.
We need to just control the
decline of our world view
and stop the boulder from
rolling down the hill on us,
a little bit.
If we can slow it down
it's a huge win, right?
But, it's coming for us either way.
That's all bullshit.
That's not true.
And culture is something that
can be shifted on a paradigm
and can move quickly.
And if you play it right and
if you speak the language
that the new audiences
of the world are speaking
then you can be the person
who creates the culture.
And who really does paradigm shifts.
Look at what Kanye's doing right
now inside of his industry.
Dr.Dre is gonna produce a
Christian album with Kanye.
We could do a whole show on
all the dimensions there,
but, my god, that's a paradigm shift.
And that happened with Trump
where for the first time
in my lifetime, and I was born
in the last years of Reagan,
first time in my lifetime it wasn't about
controlled decline for conservatism.
It wasn't about giving up
and just stopping the boulder
from crushing us.
It was about, no, we will move
the boulder back up the hill.
And we can put this
boulder back up on the hill
and put our enemies, or
put the opposing side
on their hindquarters
and roll it down on them
and make them fight us for territory.
And so, I know it's a
meme, Dave, I get it,
but it literally is winning and losing.
I like winners, they're losers.
It really is winning and
losing if you come at it
from a standpoint where
you haven't lost entirely
I love that.
And guess what?
That's what young people are attracted to.
Young people are attracted
to people who win.
They're attracted to winners.
They're attracted to optimism.
They're attracted to your
show for these exact reasons.
And, may he rest in peace, Kobe Bryant,
I mean the guy was a winner
in so many aspects of his life
and he exuded the optimism
and he loved America.
I found this old viral clip of him talking
about being.
- I shared it, it's amazing.
- On team U.S.A. and it's amazing.
He was even asked, this
was a couple years ago,
he was asked, is that cool to say
America's the best country in the world?
He's like, it's cool for me.
People are attracted to that, right?
And there's thousands of people down
at the Staples Center right now
because that attracted people.
And for the first time in my life
conservatism kind of has that,
like that winning sensibility
with all of our new heroes
and with this new "Avengers"
cast of conservatives
and they way that we are
conquering the internet.
We are destroying the
left on the internet.
We are winning the meme wars,
it's not the clone wars,
like we are winning the meme wars.
- The left can't meme.
- They cannot meme.
Like we are winning, for the first time,
It's very very exciting.
And so, the people who
like controlled losing,
I don't like that about
modern conservatives.
Sorry for the long answer,
but I really feel passionate about this.
- Dude, that's how you end an interview.
No apology necessary.
For those of you who are not on Twitter,
you might wanna follow
@BennyJohnson just for the memes,
but you put him up on Instagram
and all those other places
where the kids are today.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was fun, we'll have to do this,
maybe we'll have to write a
new "Star Wars" story together.
- Oh my god.
- Is that where this all heads?
- Yes, yes, I want to.
- With Bloomberg as baby Yoda.
- With Bloomberg (laughing)
with Bloomberg as baby Yoda.
- Has anyone done that?
I mean, has anyone made that
where you put Bloomberg's
head on baby Yoda
and done a little video?
I mean, here, I'm handing you something.
- Okay, I have to go, I have
to go do that right now.
- You have to get the hell out of here.
- That's gonna be the next thing I post.
That's gonna be the next meme.
- Alright, we're done.
- Bloomberg as baby Yoda.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.